hey leute und herzlich willkommen zu
einer weiteren mord vorstellung und zwar
von dem too much tnt motto zehn kreise
der tum hat stehen thema und ich
versuche mich damals ein bisschen
zweigleisig zu erhalten setzt der mord
oder die modifikation dass ich versuche
mich zu die modifikation umzuschwenken
also braucht es gar nicht weiter
rummeckern aber das ist soll jetzt
eigentlich mal 75 das thema handy
hersteller nämlich das thema ist die
teams stehen thema und zwar was der was
der name schon sagt von der modifikation
es werden ziemlich ziemlich viele neue
tnt arten hinzugefügte zwar genau 10 1 1
2 3 4 5 6 7 auf 19 diese vier sind fast
das gleiche aber ich werde das erst mal
ganz kurz in den kräftigen rezepten
zeigen
ihr könnt ihr das normale tnt wenn ihr
die systeme so zu einem ganz normalen
fieldings quadrat blog tut dann bekommt
er ein t x 5 das hat die fünffache
explosion von einem normalen tnt weil
ich kann ich ganz kurz explosion von
einem normalen tnt zeigen seht ihr das l
bereue ich mache hier
also das ist die explosion von einem
normalen tnt das hier ist ein tnt x 5
lassen wir das mal explodieren ja das
ist noch so ein kleiner back in dem
modus hier
da ist die explosion fünfmal so gross
und ihr seht wahrscheinlich schon kaum
bleibt auf jeden fall dran wir jede
menge explosionen haben wollt tnt mal 20
ist dann einfach tnt mal 15
quadratmetern 20 den t x 110 x 20 im
quadrat an 100 und es gibt auch noch den
t x 500 da packt er die einfach die 100
ryan und ich denke 20 und 100 muss ich
euch jetzt nicht unbedingt das was wir
alle sehen wollte c500 da fliege ich
allerdings mal ein bisschen weiter weg
weil ich das schon ein bisschen angst
hab das dann eine komplette welt ein
bisschen zerstört wird
ich mache das einfach klatschen angst
ich wette das stützt er alles ab gleich
mein komplettes spiel und alles ich
hab's noch einmal probiert ich hab mich
nicht getraut bist ja okay ich hab's
gezündet ich habe gesagt ich hab's
gezündet ich hab's gezündet hallo
freunde
ich glaube es jetzt jeden moment
abstützen hallo
das ist ein gutes zeichen
zumindest tut sich irgendwas gott was
sagt das a o mein gott walther okay
leute ich glaube da tut sich was gerade
einfach tief durchatmen
einatmen ausatmen 60 fps des petit
couronne hallo oder war mal wieder eine
bewegung das ist ja schön also das ist
gerade echt krass ihr seht ich hätte ich
jetzt nicht zeigen soll mit 500 l
ich hätte echt nicht zeigen sollen ich
bin echt zu 1000 leute wissen
ich mache ganz kurz gesehen zuvor wieder
okay da bin ich wieder wie ihr seht es
gar nichts passiert ganz einfach weil
ich das gerade mit den task-manager
beendet habe und na ja also es ist mein
pc ist somit der schlechteste denen es
gibt ja zwei nein weg aber minecraft und
spieler darauf gewalt nein gar nicht
ich versuche ich das ganze jetzt mal 100
bäume zu zeigen müsste fünftel davon so
ich glaube das wird auch einigermaßen
lenken
aber ich hoffe einfach mal dass es
funktioniert weil ich möchte euch das
echt gerne zeigen diese riesen explosion
es gibt auch noch so einen meteor tnt
ein flat baum tnt mining flat beuermann
hat schon explosion gehört und da seht
ihr das ist 100 m
das ist 100 stell dich mal vor 500 das
ist ein riesiger radius ist riesig das
velo kam es zu meiner kiste hingegangen
also das ist 100 wenn ihr sitzt ungefähr
nachfolgt ist komplett abgestürzt kann
ich leider nicht sagen tut mir sehr leid
aus wissenschaftlichen gründen
überspringt mit diese maßnahme einfach
und machen wir direkt mal weiter und
zwar mit dem meteor tnt das ist der
grösste heftigste tnt der allgemeinen
hinzugefügt wurde damen
da wird aus obsidian gemacht außen rum
dann in lhasa backe dann ein thema 501
hat meiner mediathek kann ich aber ganz
zum ende machen und dann einfach mal
abwarten und einfach laufen lassen hier
und da kann ich ihnen noch immer zeigen
das ist mit dem thema 20 und optimieren
das kann ich euch zeigen und zwar die
flat baum tnt eine bestimmte eigenschaft
übrigens den sieg nach so sieht ich mal
kurz sieht der ist so 1 6 2 6 6 1 5 0 1
22 damit im dschungel gespannt wenn ihr
über geflogen und siehe da hinten auf
einmal diese pyramide und ich weiß nicht
ich in dem immer sieht es bei dir ist
immer eine pyramide irgendwo da drin
außerdem ist das hier ein ganz cooler
ecken
das ist hier so ein symposion der
gebühren und ja also wie kann ich bin so
neugierig was in den pyramiden so drin
ist wenn er diamanten oder so drin sind
dann würde ich auf jeden fall sagen wo
bitte ist aber derzeit einen älteren
nächste gut ich zeige euch jetzt mal
kommen dass tnt kam einfach hier drin
zünden
und zwar dass eine bestimmte
eigenschaften kommt uns nicht drin sind
hier einfach so zünden
so achtet mal den titel
david war eine nachricht bekommen und
zwar dieses tnt gilt alles oder das
springt also die luft was darüber ist
und nicht was da total ist das ist
eigentlich ganz cool wenn irgendwie
einen riesigen wald hat mit dem wollte
weg macht einfach tnt anwaltes weg jung
wo wir können das einfach mal im
dschungel nachher noch testen euch wie
vor ort probiert auf jeden fall aus
daumen hoch wenn ihr diese modifikation
geld findet sich dann haben wir hier
warte um ich wollte ich erst mal zeigen
ich zeige euch jetzt erstmal die
crafting prozent danach spielen mir oh
mann ich will die ganze zeit zum spielen
das richtig geil dieser mund wer diese
bot man mir dass ich dich an gewöhnen
dass mit diese modifikation immer
dermott gesagt habe
so also ob die lupe genommen wir
brauchen oben drei unten drei torch ist
an tnt mal fünf machte er mit normal tnt
und eine flat bonn
dann bekommen wir diese mining flat bonn
da gibt's noch eine motion tnt dies ist
auch sehr geil ausprobieren man
schneller jetzt viel wasser einmal
einfach so in seinem kompass in der
mitte mining flat pop damit kommt der
ausschuss dem rapper ice-t sind viele
lehrer wird immer mit einem thema 20 in
der mitte damit kommt der everest tnt
und haus tnt ist auch das allerletzte
mich hier raus probieren das oben
cobblestone drei dann rechts links glas
unten links unten rechts fackeln und
damit zu einem kräftig tab in der mitte
thema fünfter bekommt ihr haustier so
jetzt kann ich weitermachen also erst
mal links mining freitag in den dünn
dünnen den achter steht wir hätten ja
schon noch so was natürlich das ist man
dann seht ihr was die mining netbook
macht ihr denkt man nicht acht jetzt
wird noch ein bisschen habe vorhin im
test hat so ein bisschen gehabt deswegen
wollte ich dass nichts passiert na ja
und zwar macht ihr übernimmt diese bombe
für euch die arbeit im untergrund zum
beispiel und zwar setzt sich auch noch
ganz viel geld in das heißt wenn ich
jetzt mal im untergrund gehen jungs
direkt links wir haben uns angewöhnt
direkt unter dem unter der pyramide war
so eine fette schlucht man probiert den
sieg auf jeden fall aus
guckt und wenn ihr ihn wie unter der
welt auf jeden fall so ein bisschen
fahren wollt könnt ihr so ein paar
mining diesen sätzen blabla ich zeige
euch das jetzt noch ein bisschen auch
man das ist so geil ich will damit 1000
jahren herum spielen und mein
schreibtisch in die kommentare so kann
macht doch ein blitz play mit dem mit
der modifikation weil das werde ich
machen
die zweite sache wie sagt man ein
display mit einem thema aufwand ist doch
unlogisch schreibe mir viele leute sich
letztens mit mods machen soll mach doch
links
naja jetzt kommen wir zu rutschen
washington dts befinden sich somit das
aller geilste schaut euch an
check out this was mit meiner stimme
nahtlos wahrscheinlich hat jetzt
aufgewacht bin und gestern ein bisschen
lang war also kreiert einen ozean
dann haben wir beste finde ich nicht
ganz so toll dass man einfach hier
warten wir mal ab dann seht ihr was
damit gemeint ist
ihr denken was passiert nix allerdings
hatte hier unten ist ingo eine explosion
haben was er oder war das oben hat man
glaube ich die koffer tag war die
website bomben oder haben einfach im web
based on parade tnt weiter ich mich auch
schon bei dem trading artikel gefragt
was diese bombe macht weil ach so ach ja
ja das ist eine bombe die macht
anschuldigung zu mir leid das machte das
ist eine bombe die macht um euch herum
das komplette wasser weg das ist zum
beispiel damit ihr sehen auslöschen
können oder flüsse oder so aber deswegen
hat es auch da gerade nicht geklappt
daher stimmt guckt euch an da ist das
ganze wasser weg das kann es ja auch
noch mal machen
ich glaub ich mach irgendwann mal so ein
fan video wo ich einfach mehr
sonneninsel rotsee und da ganz viele von
diesem tnt web arrays kompakt dann haben
wir nachher einen riesigen krater des
tieres dienstag schreibt man bitte in
die kommentare auf die so empfand video
haben wollt so jetzt kommt ihr zum haus
tnt haus tnt ich das allergrößte quasi
zu hilfe als exportiert man haut fliegt
in die luft
auf einmal ist am haus wird auf einmal
so ein haus gebaut ganz cool dass
normales tnt normales die ntp dass alle
heftigst ersetzt das finde ich
allerdings guckt euch das an und ist
explodiert man das richtig heftig war
jetzt mache komm mit wir machen jetzt
mal hier so kleinen wer glaubt man spaß
ich werde nicht ohne grund in kraft da
hier nicht so ernst hier alles so ein
bisschen schillig
oh mein gott
house orgie hatte mal wenn ich jetzt
hier eingehen könnte ich besuche meine
nachbarn gut
ihr seht dass ich relativ viel spaß an
dieser modifikation habe wenn ihr auch
so viel spaß daran habt ihr euch das
video gefallen hat will ich mich meinen
daumen hoch freuen
schaffen wir 1300 3 1 1 1 3376 dass wir
auf jeden fall richtig keller
da schreibt aber in die kommentare
gefallen hat jetzt genau passend nacht
und auch die kommentare schreiben ob ich
so ein fan video machen soll was morgen
kommt oder so wo ich einfach mal einen
kompletten ozean auslöste
also dann bis zum nächsten mal freunde